ANTHONY BUSHONG: So Steph,
why are we in your garage?
STEPHANIE WONG: I
thought you said
we were building stuff, right?
ANTHONY BUSHONG:
No, I was talking
about automating builds with
Google Cloud Build, not that.
STEPHANIE WONG: Oh,
Google Cloud Build.
You mean the one that
lets you orchestrate
build steps that run
as container images.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Exactly.
And this means that
each build step
can do anything a container
can, such as executing
a script or a binary.
So let's look at how you
can use Cloud Build today
to automate a simple
Terraform workflow in a way
that you might see a small team
run infrastructure as code.
Now, as a developer, I may want
to edit our team's Terraform
code on a dev branch to create
a new node pool to accommodate
a more CPU-intensive workload
than our Kubernetes Engine
cluster currently allows for.
I can do this by updating
our Terraform code
with a new node pool resource.
This node pool will be
called Olympic Pool.
And we can commit those changes
to a development branch.
This way we can
actually use Cloud Build
to create an approval workflow
as opposed to me actually
applying changes to our
infrastructure from Terraform
locally.
We'll do this using
Cloud Build's notion
of build triggers.
You'll see that my
first build trigger
is set to kick off a
build off of any push
to a non-master branch.
Because I changed the
Terraform configuration
on the dev branch, our build
has already been triggered.
So when we actually
dive into the build,
you'll see that it's comprised
of two distinct build steps,
each running in a container
with the Terraform binary.
The first build step will
initialize Terraform,
and the second will
show us what resources
will be created with
the updated code
without actually
creating those resources.
In this case, it will
be one new node pool.
And we can actually see
this in the logs from those
build steps in the
Cloud Build UI.
STEPHANIE WONG: So if we
wanted to, we could run more
build steps to, let's
say, run test suites,
or actually apply this
to a staging environment.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Precisely.
That's the idea.
This is a very
simple illustration.
Build steps are actually
customizable to the point where
you should use them to
represent the workflow that
fits your culture.
So the two use cases
that you just mentioned,
they're definitely patterns
that you can adopt.
STEPHANIE WONG: So in this
demo, how will these changes
be realized in production?
ANTHONY BUSHONG: With another
build trigger, of course.
So once I've actually pushed
those changes to the dev
branch, we're actually going
to create a pull request
against the master branch.
This is what will actually
allow for our infrastructure
to be realized in production.
You'll see here that a new
node pool resource is now
going to be created.
So we'll create
that pull request.
Typically, this introduces
a level of approval
where we can
actually have someone
with the proper permissions
review these changes
and give the approval to
actually merge the pull
request.
So once we actually merge the
pull request into the master
branch, we will
actually be invoking
our second build trigger.
This second build
trigger is actually
setup to run on any change
to the master branch
as defined here.
And you'll see that we actually
have a different Cloud Build
YAML file for this
build trigger.
In this case, what
we're doing here
is we're actually
adding a third build
step using the same
Terraform container
image that we had previously.
In this case, we'll
now be able to apply
those actual infrastructure
changes with Terraform.
So because we've actually
merged dev into master,
our build has been
triggered to actually run
with those three build steps.
So you'll see here that we still
have the Terraform container
image running in it, plan, and
now we have the third step that
says apply, and auto approve.
So it happens that's
because we actually
were able to merge
something into master,
this build was then triggered
to actually apply those changes,
as opposed to the
previous build,
which just ran a plan so
that we could introspect
what we wanted to create.
So because that build
has actually run,
let's look in our GKE cluster.
And we'll see here that the
node pool called Olympic Pool is
actually being created.
Google Cloud Build can easily
make your workflow automated
and help you easily enable
continuous building, testing,
and deployment.
STEPHANIE WONG: Don't
forget to like, comment,
and subscribe for more great
Google Cloud Platform content.